if I had it all to do over again knowing
what I know now
um I would have preferred not to sell a
spec screenplay
what script did you sell for a million
dollars
wow um so the script I sold for a
million dollars was something called
Stanley's cup and this is like at this
point it's kind of like ancient history
it was 1995 and I was approached by a
producer who um had this idea for a
hockey movie and they
he went to a another writer who was not
available so you know I guess my agent
at that time felt I had a similar
writing style to the writer he really
wanted and so he agreed to develop it
with me so we developed it out together
and
um you know and then kind of
I remember reading it before
doing the big distribution and I had
this weird experience I I uh read the
script and got teary at the end at the
climax of My Own Story which really
doesn't happen that much so I mean maybe
yeah while watching my Bar Mitzvah video
I'll get a little weepy but the but
while reading the script generally I I'm
not affected that way and I went oh I
think I might have something here
because it just it
you know it just touched me in some
weird way even though I had literally
just finished the script I was just
rereading it so uh so we went out with
the script and
um like almost immediately started
getting interest it's like we went out
with the script on a Tuesday
um and almost immediately started
getting interest and it was kind of by
Thursday night there was an offer on the
table from
um I believe it was from Disney
for 250 thousand dollars which was
you know more money than I'd ever seen
in my entire life and then I'd been
working for the previous couple of years
so I was I was a working screenwriter at
that time but I hadn't sold a spec so so
250 000 at in one chunk seemed like a
really swell idea to me and I get a call
from my agent
um this is on that Thursday night who
says he goes I don't think you should
take it I went really he goes I think
there's more money out there
I went okay
so I just talk it over with my wife you
know it's like and go
you know we're gonna say no to 250 000
and she's like okay you know let's do
this so they turned it down and then the
next day I was getting like phone calls
like every 25 30 minutes it's like
there's now an offer for three there's
an offer for 375 that's an offer for 450
and it just kept going up until it
finally hit eight hundred thousand
dollars
um against a million one so you know in
the business that's considered a million
dollar
spec sale
um because if the movie had gotten made
there would have been that extra 300 000
that have wrote it up to a million one
and finally my agent says I think this
is the offer to take and the crazy part
about it was that the um the company
that
finally got it
um was a division of Disney so Disney
was basically bidding against Disney and
like bidding it up so I was like okay
that works for me but uh yeah that was
like that Friday night you know went to
bed going that was a pretty good week
yeah that was a very exciting week you
don't get weeks like that uh very often
but um but and and not to not to
be a cold bucket of water on my own
story but I remember going to bed that
night going oh
I'm done that's great I don't have to I
don't have to hustle anymore I don't
have to you know I felt like you know
really made it end the the truth of it
is that yeah I gotta bump a little bit
like then like on the heels of that
immediately got another job just because
I was sort of the flavor of the month
kind of thing
um but it you know you think you sell a
spec screenplay and you know you've made
it it's not a career that's just a very
lucky job but it's not a career so so
there's still a lot of career building
to be done which I didn't appreciate as
a young youngish writer selling a big
Spectrum player like that but um but it
it didn't suck
would it teach you about sort of knowing
your worth because it sounds like you
were very close to taking the 250 000
yeah
so
I don't know that it taught me anything
about knowing my worth because like
anybody who knows me knows that I've
overestimated my own worth
pretty much from infancy so so I just
felt like it's all about what the market
will bear kind of thing like you know
like if if that screenplay was available
today would that ever be an 800 000
against
1.1 million screenplay I doubt it
um it's just it just changed but at that
period of time
it was
that's what screenplays was selling for
it was I mean people if they want to
look up a little bit of film history
look up like spec sales from you know
mid 1995 and you'll see it started with
um cable guy really
um and that sold for I think 750 000
um and that suddenly became sort of the
Touchstone even to the point where my
agent
said when somebody said what's it going
to take to take this script off the
market and the response was Cable Guy
money
so that that became and there was just
this rash of spec sales at that time I
think Joe esterhaus
um sold something for four million
dollars and Shane black yeah I don't
know if that was that was before or
after last Boy Scout or long kiss
goodnight but it was it was one of those
that also sold for like two million you
know so it was like it was getting into
crazy crazy numbers
um at that period of time so I always
felt that my value is fine and you know
it's just what people are willing to
spend on it I mean I've had scripts
since then that I feel are just pound
for pound much better it's just as far
as conceptually as far as the story goes
and and depth and my own ability as a
writer and just never sold
right so it's like you never know so you
know so if I if I if I
Define my worth based on a piece of
material then that particular Friday
when I went to bed you know my value
would be really high and the Fridays
that I went to bed when I didn't sell
something that week my value would be
low I don't know my value is consistent
it's just what people are willing to to
pay for it and Things Come and Go I mean
it's like I had a script that I wrote
literally in
1989 that didn't get made until uh
2006. so 16 years from the time I wrote
it and it was a good script
who knows but you can't for sure you
cannot if you if you let the if you let
the
you know
vague sense of yeah I'm only my worth is
only defined by my material you'll
you know you'll want to get out of this
business really quickly
how does payment generally work when a
screenwriter sells a screenplay oh it
it's a very it's a very fun day because
um it takes about a couple weeks you
know between the time because you sell
it and then business Affairs now has to
hash out all the contractual bits and
pieces of it and so that's a couple of
weeks worth of work and then once the
contracts are all signed then just
somebody usually your agent says we have
a check here for you because
um and then you get you know you see all
the deductions come out you know it's
like you know it's it feels like if I
said oh yeah the the selling price was
eight hundred thousand dollars on that
spec screenplay on Stanley's cup but um
I
forget how much the check was four but
this 25 came off immediately off the top
yeah 10 to a manager 10 to age and five
to my lawyer right and uh you know so
you start going you know okay so that
came off and then I think I think I was
still like a W-2 I don't I don't know if
I had my loanout company at that time so
now taxes come out anyway you end up
with probably by the time you get done
30 percent of of the thing so it's a
little heartbreaking but still it's
still a lot of money you know it's like
you know you get a check like that and
um I remember picking up the check I was
with William Morris at the time and
remember picking up the check from them
and like walking it over to the bank to
deposit it because I didn't even want to
like I didn't even want to
like carry it home and then go to the
bank later I just want to go right from
there to this other than nothing nothing
would happen to it so um yeah it's it's
a it's a it's a pretty straightforward
you know um process with the exception
that you know you don't often hold a
check that has so many zeros on it
what did this experience teach you about
the experience of selling a big spec
screenplay like that
really kind of taught me that it's a
I mean it's everything you think going
into it and then it's sort of
processing it afterwards so going into
it you think like I was saying before
great I've made it I don't have to worry
anymore right and then afterwards you go
oh no I actually still have to come up
with stuff people aren't going to keep
handing me things to do just because I
sold this screenplay once and um it just
taught me that it's you constantly have
to hustle and and not be afraid to
reinvent yourself and generate ideas
um one of my one of the agents that I
had at that time
um had what I still think is
kind of cynical yet might be really
accurate good advice
um when I was asking like what should I
work on next and he goes he goes I don't
know but make it derivative and make it
quick
that ID just have to it's I mean
occasionally like yeah I haven't I'm
taught
screenwriting in seminars for a while
but when I did I would usually start
with
asking everybody who is coming to hear
me talk
um like how long does it take you to
write a screenplay and I'll go you know
if it takes you you know everybody takes
you know uh three months raise your hand
and you know a couple of hands would go
up right you know six months you know
more hands would go up right you know
eight months to a year you know probably
that's where the bulk of the hands went
up and I said
anyone who did not raise your hand for
three months you're probably not going
to make it in the business
because you don't have time if you if
you want to make it if you if you want
to
have a career
it's going to take you
10 years of slugging away at it you know
slogging away at it to launch a career
and if you're writing one screenplay you
know every year it's like okay well that
great that was 10 screenplays but you're
not going to get any good until you get
to your seventh or eighth screenplay
anyway
so
just bang them out you know like learn
something from every screenplay so make
it and make a derivative at that time
just meant you know oh uh you know
there's a movie that you really liked
from 10 years ago you know if there's
something derivative from that that
still speaks to you
you should work on that but also don't
work on it for a year just paying it out
so I mean I was I was you know at that
period of time just trying to be a
machine I mean I I'd be cranking three
four scripts a year specs yeah just
because you just had to keep it's like
buying lottery tickets right it's like
you know buy one lottery ticket hey buy
100 lottery tickets you got maybe a
greater chance statistically so every
screen plays a lottery ticket so so
that's kind of like what I I learned
from it is that yeah just you know
constantly have to hustle you can feel
good about yourself for a little bit
after some success and you want to take
the successes you want to feel good
about yourself but but don't let the
successes Define you or take you off
your guard or make you feel you know
lazy you know or you know ah you know I
don't have to do anything anymore no
constantly have to do stuff
in some sense did it almost create more
pressure
because now more is expected of you no
interestingly
it
and this is going to be kind of a weird
thing to say
if I had it all to do over again knowing
what I know now
um I would have preferred not to sell a
spec screenplay
money goes away that doesn't last what
you want to do is build a career so what
happens
or in my experience as a result of
selling that spec screenplay it
artificially I was I was a solid writer
at that point I you know I think I had
worked on on the like the very first
thing I did was like a script doctoring
gig
um for
um uh the amazing panda adventure for
Warner Brothers that was like the first
real paying oh no that wasn't that
wasn't the first paying me the first
paying thing I did was
um was actually I got paid to write
Bloodsport too right but that was you
know kind of like not a major studio
type of thing
um but it got me into the guild but the
first Studio job that I had uh was for
Warner Brothers and for the amazing
panda adventure and I think it paid
forty thousand dollars for like two
weeks of work which is even today that's
doesn't suck right but I think it was
forty thousand dollars for two weeks of
work as a script doctor right because
they like my dialogue and you know they
needed a dialogue polish on it so I did
that then they like the work so much
that I got
um I was the first writer on Dennis the
Menace II right and that paid 90 000.
right so in the banana and that was
two months of work or so right so you
know and then I think after Dennis the
Menace II I think I optioned something
for not a lot of money oh but then I got
then I got hired to
um to
I don't say script doctor but to do a
pass on what turned into an Olsen twins
movie It Takes Two so I was like the
second writer on them I don't have a
credit and we can discuss the joys of
writer's Guild arbitration at some point
if you'd like if I didn't get a credit
on that one but that paid 150 000. so
like I I was I was sort of like building
like my quote was going up organically
and naturally and then from 150 jumped
to 800 000 so that artificially inflated
my quote because now it's like my agents
are in this weird situation where it's
like well you know we want you have to
work on on the screenplay what's his
quote and you can't say well 175 you
know like or 200 because of the last
quote you know the quote now gets
artificially inflated so I'm sure there
were a number of jobs that were just was
they would have been happy to pay 250
but not happy to pay five or seven fifty
or something like that you know what I
mean so
so in a weird way
it kind of priced me out of the market
um you know and then I had to take a
step back and
you know and kind of sort of re-jig you
know my career and say let me look at
television also let me like expand so
you know so it was kind of I don't want
to say that that selling the spec was
the worst thing that ever happened to me
it clearly wasn't but with the benefit
of hindsight and a little bit more
knowledge of how the business
works it was like
you know I don't know but then I'm sure
there were plenty of people out there
who you know come from nowhere sell a
big spec and
you know just
yeah that's their you know that becomes
their
career path and and it's all fine I
think what I think what really
what didn't help the most if that's the
way to put it is that the fact that the
movie never got made you know had the
movie got made and it was a hit that
that changes one's career trajectory so
this was was purchased it it was it had
a um
a very uh
specific time frame with which it had to
go into production
um like it was purchased in May and it
was supposed to go into production by
October it had Dennis Leary attached to
Star and Chris Farley as the co-star
um just really it's sort of like weird
kind of sports comedy about the Stanley
Cup going missing right so um so at
Dennis Leary and Chris Farley and the
director was Jim Abrams you know from
you know airplane and you know the
Zucker you know Abrams team
um so it had like all the elements in
place to be fast-tracked into production
but but Jim Abrams was going through a
dark period in his life because he had a
son who was uh very ill
um so he was like very who I think the
sun is fine or was fine you know
afterwards but he he really wanted to
make it less of a silly comedy and get
like more serious of it so they hired
some other writers to come in after me
and they did a draft and it became kind
of very serious and Studio didn't like
it they liked the the funnier version of
it but now it's like it's gone down and
they paid those guys 500 I have a 500
500 000 to rewrite the screenplay that
they already paid you know eight hundred
thousand dollars for and then it became
sort of unusable and so then they were
in the process of going back to say okay
let's kind of go back to what we like
um and then Chris Farley passed this
away and then so it was like this sort
of domino effect of just
ill-timed Fortune
um so had it got made I think sort of
the lessons would have been potentially
different but um well I love where you
took it at what point did you realize
this isn't happening
um when I I as a courtesy I was sent to
the rewrite of the script
um and um and I read it I went
I just felt that everything in my gut
that this thing is just not not
shootable
um it it was I mean the script was I
mean at the risk of sounding like an old
TV guy thing it was like a zany comedy
you know you know road trip comedy you
know with hockey's Stanley Cup and this
and the rewrite turned it like no joke
basically into rain man
um you know you know they turned it into
like a my zany comedy turned into like a
serious exploration of the problems of
the mentally ill yeah I was like you
know you couldn't have gone more
different I'm going
who wants to see this I mean it was like
so at that point I was going okay I
think we're in trouble here and then and
then there's sort of a cascading series
of events from there